ạ
Alo ạ Alo Alo
alo thợ chẳng biết do mic mic đang bé
hay như nào
nữa Alo ạ Ờ các bạn nghe thấy rõ không
alo alo alo
alo chỉnh
alo kiểu thế suốt đúng không Ờ mic to
hơn nhiều hiểu chưa
vọng các bạn không bị điếc tai thôi
cái gì nó biến thành đỏ chót rồi nên
chắc là nó đủ to rồi đúng không ạ à đầu
tiên là xin chào các bạn mình hôm nay
thì thì Như tiêu đề các bạn thấy thì bây
giờ mình sẽ sang
phân
sẽ chắc không dùng thử học chỉ sẽ cùng
nhau phân tích về website bán hàng
panch
nay để đợi tôi một tí Thực ra là tôi tôi
vẫn đang hơi bỡ ngỡ tùy Lộ đúng kiểu Lâu
lắm rồi mới livestream vì vừa nãy tôi ấn
tôi chọn cái á
livestream mà tôi nghĩ là tôi chọn để mà
kiểu kiểu chuẩn bị lên ý nó ấn start
luôn vãi trưởng nên là bây giờ tôi vẫn
còn đang cần phải xem lại nhiều cái Đợi
tí Đợi tí à Đây đúng đúng rồi đúng link
rồi
nó
bị
cắt Tôi chỉnh nó là cho nó xuống rồi mà
Windows hiện sắp tới chuyển Uber thì
biết là lon hiện không support cho linus
recom công cụ tương tự
Dragon Ờ cái này thì bạn hỏi trong
discord ấ Mình thấy có nhiều bạn sử dụng
UB và gọi như là bản thân Uber Nó là
kiểu Tôi nhớ không lầm ấy nó là sẵn là
nó là máy ảo rồi Thường là Windows
với ví dụ ma này thì không có máy ảo nên
là mới phải cài cái kia để mà chạy còn
cái này thì u hay là linus thì tôi nh
nhớ nó là máy ảo Sẵn rồi nên là chạy Mọi
thứ ổn hơn rất nhiều
ờ và nó chung là khi mà bạn đã chuyển
qua u và linus thì đúng kiểu
bạn Bạn lên trình rất là nhanh bởi vì
khả năng tự học của bạn về mấy cái đấy
phải đủ nhiều mới Bạn mới làm quen được
ấy nó không dễ dùng
Ờ tôi thấy tôi nếu mà xếp thứ tự thì
thường là mình vẫn quen dùng đâu nhất
cho đến ma xong rồi mới đến linus các
thứ chào anh rất vui khi viết câu hỏi
anh chuyện là Thi vàở thuộc thuộc khối
nhà nước tại địa phương em sinh sống thì
không đạt được mời làm cộng tác viên và
được trở lương đẩy theo tiếp tục cộng
tác viên hay à đầy sang không lương
để hay lựa chọn một công ty khác để em
sang đấy thức tập không lương trong thời
điểm của năm như này với người anh lời
khuyên anh
vừa mới khuyên một bạn về cái vụ l cũng
liên quan đến A công việc cũng kiểu bạn
ý định nhảy việc hay là nghỉ việc gì gì
đó
Ừ Thực ra đây là tình hình chung của mỗi
người tôi thường hay nói với sinh viên
Đó là
một khi mà mình lấn gấn cái gì đó Kể cả
không phải mỗi công việc mà thậm chí là
cả mối quan hệ chẳng hạn đó là khi mà
mình cảm thấy lấn cấn Khi mà mình không
cảm thấy thoải mái thì tốt nhất là
mình
à Không hẳn là tôi không khuyên mấy ông
là hơi tí mấy ông bỏ cuộc nhưng mà
Ừ nhưng mà kiểu mấy ông sẽ kiểu mấy ông
nghĩ nó rất là nhiều nó sẽ ấ kiểu làm
cho mấy ông kiểu làm mọi thứ nó không
được toàn tâm toàn ý nữa ấy mấy ông hiểu
nên
là nên là tôi thường khuyên đó là mấy
ông phải cố hết sức Trong một khoảng
thời gian khi mà mình cảm thấy mình đã
cố hết sức rồi thử hết mọi cách rồi mà
nó vẫn khiến mình bị lấn cấn khiến mình
cảm thấy không phù hợp cho dù mình thay
đổi góc nhìn bản thân rồi thì chắc là
lúc đấy thì mình mới nên từ bỏ
người là là đâm lao phải theo lao tôi
quan điểm Nó là
kiểu việc Thứ nhất là mình nên thử đã
nhiều người thì ngại thử nhiều người
ngại thử ở đây
là một là ngại thử cái
mới à Ngại thử đến nỗi là họ không dám
đi xin việc mới chẳng hạn Ít ra thì mình
có còn mạnh dạn hơn cái điều đấy mình
cảm thấy có vấn đề thì mình cũng mình
cũng kiểu mạnh dạn dám nghỉ mạnh dạn dám
thay đổi theo tôi thì
ờ tuổi trẻ mình mình trải nghiệm các thứ
Tứ trước chứ chứ về trước khi ổn định
thật sự tôi trước có cái ảnh bìa nó
là ví dụ đời người mình thì mỗi ngày chỉ
đời người mỗi người chỉ gọi như à mỗi
ngày mỗi người chỉ có 24 giờ thôi đúng
không ạ thì 1 PH3 là dành để ngủ nhá thì
1/3 là dành cho công việc 1/3 là dành
cho nửa kia của mình đúng không ạ thì nó
là 1/3 cuộc đời đấy đúng không ạ 1/3
cuộc đời mình thì mình sẽ phải làm công
việc gì mình cảm thấy gọi là nó cũng
tương đối ổn
đi có thể là tôi không thể khuyên mấy
ông được là mấy ông cứ cắm đầu theo đuổi
đam mê rồi đam mê sẽ sẽ trả cho ông một
cái khoản gì đó Bởi vì ngày công nghệ
ông tin này th ra nó còn đỡ nhưng mà tùy
đấy tù có người không thực sự là hợp đâu
nhưng mà Ngà công nghệ công tin này tính
ra là bây giờ nó chia ra rất nhiều loại
không phải mỗi cứ cắm đầu vào Lập trình
là được nhé các bạn có thể làm ba các
bạn thể làm rất rất nhiều thứ cái bây
giờ nó phát triển Nó rộng lắm
công việc mà ông đương nhiên là nó nên
là một công việc rất là thoải mái rất là
kiểu có thể tạo động lực cho ông để
những cái ngày mưa gió những ngày lạnh
lẽo như này m ông thể vùng dậy khỏi chặn
chăn để mà kiểu để mà đi làm các thứ
đúng không ạ theo tôi thì công việc
mình Nếu mà Lý Tưởng nhất thì mình vẫn
nên cố gắng chọn được công việc phù hợp
với bản thân
mình cho em hỏi cần có những kỹ năng
kiến thức quan trọng và Project thế nào
để xin làm f lel hoặc cơ hội nào lên J
geno hoặc có cần biết nhiều về Facebook
fance không Ờ tính học thêm view Thực ra
là bạn chỉ cần học đủ mấy cái và làm đủ
cái đồ án mà tôi dạy trong cái playlist
của tôi thì cũng tôi thấy là nó cũng đủ
ngưỡng hơn cả frer larel rồi vì tính ra
nó cũng gọi là đụng chạm khá
nhiều còn có cơ hội lên xo Thực ra à lên
Junior Thực ra dễ dễ thôi Nói chung là
các bạn cứ làm đồ
án thì các bạn khi đi phỏng vấn thì có
cái mà khoe thì các bạn sẽ thừa sức xin
ứng tuyển được vào và làm tầm kiểu
thường chuẩn là làm sẽ tầm 6 tháng thì
sẽ lên được mức Junio thôi còn Framework
fance thì thực ra là bạn học thêm cũng
được nhưng mà Ừ tôi nghĩ bạn cứ nên
chuyên một cái trước đã còn ja Script
thì chỉ cần đủ cơ bản giống như là tôi
sang công ty thì cũng có biết về fw fend
đâu nhưng mà kiểu có biết một tí ra
Script xong rồi công ty làm thế nào thì
mình nhảy vào xong mình copy code mình
sửa lại Bởi vì bản chất là ngôn ngữ nó
không quan trọng mình vẫn kiểu gì mình
chả thích nghi được đúng không
ạ thì ok có vẻ hết những câu hỏi mà các
bạn hỏi rồi Các bạn muốn hỏi thêm thì Ừ
tôi quên mất là tôi để không để link các
bạn hỏi nhỉ đây các bạn thể bấm vàoo đây
để để
kiểu kiểu hỏi thêm để có gì tôi sẽ giải
đáp sau
nhé thì ờ đầu tiên thì hôm nay Như tiêu
đề thì tôi sẽ phân tích cho mấy ông làm
thì như hôm trước tôi giới thiệu thì cái
pancham này là cái trang web kiểu dạng Ừ
để tôi mở cái pancham lên
có code ở đây Bây giờ tôi mở code lên
sợ nguy hiểm hơi nguy hiểm đợi tôi một
tí Đợi tí tạm tắt ra tạm tắt cái này đi
một tí để tôi tạm remove code đi
ty nên là th không được
không Không trong công ty tôi cũng là
trong web bán hàng bình thường thi mà
chính xác là Trang thương mạnh điện tử
Ờ tôi nhớ Hình như là tôi Bọn tôi đã
từng sửa cái vụ cái cái này rồi bởi vì
nó có cái header nên là chuẩn là nó sẽ
phải cần thêm header nữa nên là nó bị
lỗi cái này nên thôi kệ chúng ta tạm bỏ
qua giao diện Ờ đại khái trang web
pancham này thì nó chỉ ở trang web kiểu
bán quần áo các thứ các thứ
bán thực ra không phải mỗi bán quần áo
mà về sau sẽ còn kiểu bán đồ thủ công mỹ
nghệ Nói chung là nó nhưng mà mình cứ
hiểu hình dung nó là bán một cái sản
phẩm gì đấy đúng không ạ trang web mua
bán và nó sẽ cóở kết hợp trang web tin
tức nữa
à Thì bây giờ mình sẽ thử phân tích xem
là tôi nhớ hồi trước là tôi đã làm cái
vụ phân tích rồi tôi có database rồi thì
tôi
Bởi vì Đây máy mới chẳng nhớ kiểu tôi
đã pan cham
này kết nối
rot
này ô Ồ Chứng tỏ là kết nối được này đây
có DB như này như là tôi nghĩ là tôi sẽ
thiết kế lại cái vụ à bản database các
thứ thôi để tạo cái
này thô cứ để tạo đây vậy
Ừ có vài bảng nó sẽ tự động tạo của
thằng larel ví dụ giả sử như là
migration này password reset có cả
personal Token à Có vụ này cơ Ừ hình như
là dùng cái au của nó để có cái personal
Token
Ờ có vai cái nữa thì ví dụ như là
product hay các thứ tôi không nhớ Chính
xác là
cái đợi tôi một tí nhá Đợi tôi một
tôi tôi chỉ
ngại
ok
phân
tích H Tôi làm
cùng với người em để mà làm cho một bạn
người quen thì bạn đấy Kiểu Bọn tôi ngồi
làm phân tích các thứ thứ cũng liệt kê
ra cũng kiểu nhiều tính năng phết như
này đối với cái này Thực ra là nó mang
Thiên hướng là kiểu cho người không biết
về công nghệ đọc mấy cái phân tích này
chứ thực ra là mình không Mình cũng gọi
là thực sự là mình không cần phải đến
nỗi kiểu quá chú trọng vào mấy cái việc
này đúng không ạ Ừ đây dự án thực tế mà
đúng không đấy các bạn sẽ thấy là nó sẽ
phân tích khá là nhiều mấy cái chi tiết
nhỏ nhỏ ví dụ kiểu hover và sáng lên như
này chẳng hạn
thường thôi Tôi nghĩ là tôi sẽ cần phải
làm hẳn một cái phân tích Ờ phân tích
lại cái trang web này thực sự cần làm
những cái gì nhưng mà đợi tôi một tí tôi
đang nhớ lại thông cảm vì coi như là coi
như là bởi vì mình đang có dự án sẵn nên
là bây giờ để nhớ lại làm nó sẽ khó hơn
với việc là phân tích Từ đầu một cái dự
án đúng không Đôi khi ông là làm từ đầu
nó dễ hơn rất nhiều
được cái
repository
để bây giờ để cho mấy ông lựa chọn nhá
một là tôi tôi sẽ hướng dẫn mấy ông là
là làm hẳn một cái dự án mới tức là sẽ
gần như là xóa hết code đi làm lại phân
tích lại từ đầu bao gồm có thể thay đập
đi dat database làm lại hai là mình sẽ
dựa vào cái coi như là mình có sẵn
database rồi Đây là một cái dự án đang
chạy giả sử
Thế thì mình sẽ review code mình làm đến
đâu mình sửa sửa dần code đến đấy bản
chất
là bản chất là kiểu code thì cũng đang
có cũng đang chạy được rồi k không biết
chạy đúng hay sai thôi nhưng mà mình sẽ
phải gọi
là nói chung refactor lại nó các bạn sẽ
có hai khái niệm đó là refactor
này n
đi kệ mấy cái đi
à Có Token này chắc các bạn không nhìn
được hết cái Token đâu một cái
à
refactor và một cái là
ơ chữ này lúc to bé khó chịu nhỉ Dùng à
subex
có bạn nào Phân biệt được hai th này
không
Google nhá chúng ta chơi kiểu Giả sử Các
bạn đã từng gặp hai từ này
chưa h à à Đúng rồi hình như là tôi hôm
trước tôi có cái xem Cái vụ này
start q&a đấy
reformat
đấy sẽ đưa ra câu hỏi đúng
hỏi rồi mấy ông trả lời à Mấy ông nhìn
thấy trả lời hay là mấy ông hỏi vậy xem
nhá
q& livestream
YouTube chưa dùng cái này chị
kiểu mấy ông hỏi tôi trả lời chứ không
phải tôi hỏi mấy ông trả lời Ờ để xem
nó hiển thị danh sách Ok thơi
Ờ thôi để tôi trả lời luôn nhá Cái
refactor Tức là mình sẽ kiểu kiểu dạng
là tái cấu trúc
lại
code nhưng không sửa lại logic không sửa
logic ví dụ Giả sử là kiểu dạng là bạn
cứ hình dung về việc code các bạn nó như
một ngôi nhà đi nó kiểu dạng là nó vừa
ngôi nhà vừa là kiểu đồ đạc trong nhà
thì kiểu Các bạn thấy là mọi thứ Nếu mà
giả sử mà nó đang rất là bừa bãi thì các
bạn muốn sắp xếp nó gọn gàng lại cái này
thì nên đặt ở chỗ này cái này là chỗ kia
thì nó gọi refactor tức là kiểu mình sẽ
mình sẽ kiểu ví dụ là cái máy giặt không
được để trong phòng khách mình bê ra chỗ
khác đúng không đấy Kiểu như thế
à cái bếp Không được để trong vòng khách
đấy bếp Không được để trong vòng ngủ
mình nĩ bế Đỗ khác nghĩa là nhưng mà
logic mọi thứ hoạt động nó vẫn phải giữ
nguyên đúng không
còn reformat thì thường hay kiểu dạng là
code các bạn đang đang kiểu đang trông
nó xấu theo kiểu là là kiểu gọi như nào
nhỉ
ờ
ờ Nó là kiểu dạng là code xấu Chẳng biết
được code thế nào code xấu bây giờ nữa
rất nhiều kiểu nhưng mà đại khái là đôi
khi các bạn chỉ cần sửa lại Phả Comment
này thụt đầu dòng vào cho tiện này thì
đấy là reformat nghĩa là nó kiểu gần như
là sửa lại giao diện code chứ không có
không làm gì khác không có B code từ chỗ
này sang chỗ
khác optimize á optimize thường là tôi
sẽ không dùng cái đây Tại sao tự nhiên
tôi nhắc về vụ này bởi vì cái khi mà tôi
commit code ấ thường là tôi sẽ có những
cái kiểu là update này ở refactor
này reformat
này feature này feature nghĩa là thêm
hẳn cái gì nó mới này ví dụ Giả sử tôi
sẽ là update kiểu add colum gì Ví dụ Giả
sử
product
này đấy hoặc là thậm chí Liên Quan tính
năng nào bên tính năng create này
refactor thì tôi sẽ nói cụ thể refactor
những cái gì Ví dụ product and post như
này chẳng hạn đấy còn reformat thì thực
ra tôi không cần ghi một cái gì Tôi
thường nó thế thôi Kiểu V format nó
không ảnh hưởng logic ở đâu cả nên là nó
chuẩn là nó không được phép làm ảnh
hưởng
logic không có kiểu sửa xọa kiểu làm gì
đó thay đổi hẳn về mặt nghiệp vụ nên là
cái này tôi chỉ ghi giản như thế còn
tiếp theo là tính năng thì tính năng tôi
sẽ kiểu ví dụ là đấy
allow user can update product chẳng hạn
đấy Đây là những cái cách tôi đẩy code
lên tôi sẽ ghi commit chú thích cho cái
đoạn code mà tôi đẩy lên Nên là nên là
tôi sẽ phải phân biệt mấy ông refactor
nó khác nhau reformat ở chỗ
đấy thì đây Thế nên là tôi phải tự nhiên
tôi nói rõ về vụ này thì tôi đang hỏi
mấy ông ấy đó là mấy ông muốn tôi đập đi
làm lại từ đầu hay là tôi sẽ refactor
lại chứ không phải reformat nhá nghĩa là
tôi làm code đến đâu à Bây giờ tôi sẽ
chạy lại các tính năng để xem thứ nhất
nó có vấn đề ở đâu thì thì mình sẽ
refactor lại để sửa Tại sao tự nhiên tôi
hỏi về vụ này vì đập đi Thực ra nó rất
là dễ
và thường là khi vào công ty mới à khi
vào công ty thì mấy ông làm gì có chuyện
mấy ông được đập đi làm lại từ đầu cho
cho à chảng công ty nào cho phép bạn làm
điều đấy cả thường là các bạn sẽ các bạn
sẽ là kiểu vào cái code đang chạy đúng
không các bạn phải học Xem xem logic
đoạn đấy Kiểu xem cái nghiệp vụ logic
đoạn đấy nó như nào đúng không đương
nhiên thì tôi bảo đập đi làm lại thì các
bạn cũng sẽ hiểu luồng lúc đầu nhưng mà
bây giờ Bây giờ giả sử là chính tôi cũng
là người cũng không codt hoàn toàn cái
này nên là khi mà đập bây giờ tôi làm
đến đâu tôi sẽ đập đến đấy refactor lại
đến đấy Và tôi cũng sẽ giải thích cái
nghiệp vụ cho mấy ông thì mấy ông Sẽ có
mấy ông kiểu gì mấy ông sẽ hiểu thôi Nếu
mà Mấy ông xem xuyên suốt từ đầu đến
cuối đúng không ờ và như tôi vừa nói thì
dự án thực tế nó sẽ là như thế đó là khi
ông vào công ty rất ít công ty gọi là
kiểu mới hoàn toàn rồi ông ông mới vào
bởi vì thường là công ty setup mới mới
tinh để cho ông code những dòng code đầu
tiên ấy thì chưa chắc nó tuyển Mấy ông
không tuyển fer không tuyển Junio mà
tuyển hẳn xio đúng không Thì mấy ông
cũng sẽ không được code từ đầu đúng
không Nghĩa là nghĩa là nếu Nếu mà tôi
đập đi làm lạnh từ đầu thì chỉ có lợi
cho mấy ông Khi mà tự làm cái dự án cá
nhân thì nên làm như nào nên nên là tôi
nghĩ là bây giờ tôi
sẽ tôi Tôi nghĩ là sẽ theo hướng
refactor là động đến đâu Đập đến đấy để
cho mấy ông dễ hình dung thì nó sẽ hợp
lý hơn Ừ tôi nghĩ nó sẽ hợp lý hơn còn
bây giờ để mấy ông muốn quen với việc là
làm dự án từ đầu nên như thế nào thì
chắc là mấy ông xem cái playlist mấy cái
playlist trước của tôi thì nó hợp với
bên Junior Còn bây giờ chúng ta sẽ chính
thức là sang cái bit này nó sẽ là codt
một dự á thực tế và sẽ hướng theo code
của xio thì nó sẽ như nào bây giờ khi mà
tôi đập đến đâu để cho chắc chắn nó vẫn
chạy thì chúng ta sẽ phải viết test đấy
được chưa ạ thì tôi sẽ hướng dẫn mấy ông
về cách viết test luôn ok không ạ
à PSR 122 xong reformat lại bị khác với
người khác có nên đẩy lên không ạ Ờ thực
tế là tôi là một người chơi cũng gọi là
khá là khác biệt so khác theo kiểu là
thứ nhất là anh em còn dùng vs code tôi
biết nên là tiếp theo là này reformat
bình thường chúng ta sẽ mở cái PS r12
này hoặc thậm chí là có cái của larel
này này nhưng mà không Tôi còn theo một
tông khác nữa tôi còn chỉnh thêm một vài
cái lúc mà tôi set xong cái larel này
nên là khi mà kiểu tôi ấn cái nút
reformat lại toàn bộ code ấy thì thì nó
sẽ gọi
là nó nó đối với tôi Phả đẹp không biết
mấy ông có đẹp hay không nhưng chắc chắn
là với tôi đương nhiên là đẹp mỗi tội là
là khi mà đẩy đoạn code đấy lên ấy nó sẽ
dễ bị xung đột code với người khác Giả
sử Mọi người đang cùng code trong này
nhìn nhìn nha đấy tôi ref Ơ cái chạ cái
cái dòng này refat rồi Ừ cái này tôi
codt từ đầu nên nó refat mất rồi Đại xem
hối trước tôi là thằng code đầu cái đoạn
này thành ra là mấy không TH thấy là dấu
bằng nó nó thằng bằng nhau này nhưng mà
xếp tôi vì sao không thích nên tôi lại
phải bỏ lại thực ra dấu bằng bằng nhau
này trông cũng hay trong một vài trường
hợp nhưng về sau nó bị dài quá ấy có vài
tên biến nó dài vãi trưởng như thế này
này Đấy sa tự nhiên có dấu bằng bằng
bằng nhau thì nó bất ổn mớ không
cả cái file để mà đẩy code lên thì nó
không hề hợp lý lắm Nó sẽ xung đột code
với người khác
Ờ Bây giờ thì như tôi đã nói thì bây giờ
mình cứ tạm là động đến đây mình làm sửa
dần đến đấy nhá Thì đầu tiên thì vào
trang chủ này cái này hình như tôi nhớ
không lầm là nó là chỉ là giao diện demo
chứ thực ra đây không phải là product
thật
sự thì mình cứ xem từ trang đầu trang
chủ đầu tiên nhé Thì mình trước mình cài
hình như là tôi có cài à
Ờ tôi nhớ là tôi cài telescope rồi thì
rồi Khi mà vào trang này mặc định
telescope nó sẽ phải lên đâu xem nào xem
mở telescope lên
chưa Ở config
này
mình có T Scope chưa
mà h chưa mở Nó lên
rồi đợi tôi một tí
code để cho mọi người xem được nếu mọi
người có nhớ nhưng
kết nối quá thì đúng là máy tôi cũng
Treo
t mấy cái kiểu dạng như là ai Người code
đây á Tôi cài cái plug
in chắc là tôi sẽ trả lời Mấy ông sau
nhé Bây giờ thì kiểu tập chung chung xử
lý một cái đã mấy ông cứ chắc là mấy ông
hỏi trực tiếp ở trong cái link link này
này đúng không có cái link ở trong cái
phần mô tả ấy mấy ông cứ hỏi xong rồi
buổi sau tôi trả lời hết một lượt nó
tiện
đấy tôi dùng cái wap này
để CD pan cham này xong rồi
B CT debug tôi có cải cái debug của
thằng thằng x dbu để mà chạy cái pp st
không biết được nó đang báo lỗi nhưng mà
thôi tạm kệ đã tính
cái này chắc là tôi sẽ phải tạm để ở đâu
đó
rồi hơi khó chịu nhỉ Mình tạm đây
đây Ok chạy lại
này đó nó sẽ biết được là mình đang dùng
cái view gì dùng những câu query gì đúng
không ạ Ờ Master này foter header này
này cái này bản thân đã làm về cái
a mình đã làm kiểu dạng là chia các gọi
là cái Master à kiểu chên nhỏ nó ra từng
cái layer layout các thứ thứ thứ rồi
đúng không
ạ homepage content này Uầy có cả data
truyền vào như này xịn hết lần đầu tôi
mở cái view lên đấy Hồi trước tôi không
mở view lên đâu thì thường là tôi sẽ
code back end api thôi chứ kiểu fanel
thì không dùng larel nên là thành ra là
cũng không mở cái cái này lên để xem
config đang bị D Kate này bị lặp đi lập
lại à Không nó khác nhau ở cái này về
sau mình sẽ phải tối ưu dần mấy câu truy
vấn
trong h page controller đúng
cứ sửa dần lại
Này bạn này thì bạn đấy làm config là
kiểu hot code luôn mấy cái key các thứ
thứ như này th tôi không Phả thích kiểu
này
nay mình sửa dần mà cho dù có dù tôi
cũng không TH thích kiểu như này tôi
muốn đập đi làm lại lắm việc đập đi làm
lại nó sẽ dễ hơn rất nhiều khi mà ngồi
sửa codt nhưng mà như tôi đã nói rồi đó
là
à Tôi sẽ dạy mấy ông về cách kiểu khi mà
sửa một cái gì đó bản thân tôi cũng chưa
là người kiểu sửa nhiều như thế này nhá
Để tôi thở làm cho mấy ông xem nhá thì
đầu tiên là đầu tiên này các bạn thấy ở
đây có một cái config mod đúng không ạ
bản chất là Tôi làm à Tôi gợi ý em đấy
là có những cái mình sẽ vứt vào trong
config kiểu như này tự nhiên bạn thêm UR
th Càng Sai rồi Đ không nên có ul cái
này mình sẽ rop đi
sau đôi khi là nh Hồi trước tôi bị kiểu
khó chịu cái gì đó kiểu ví dụ Giả sử
thừa một cái cột này tôi sẽ muốn drop nó
hẳn đi luôn xong rồi Tôi làm nhưng mà
như tôi nói thì nó sẽ để lại lại có thể
để lại hậu quả rất là lớn M có những chỗ
khác đang dùng hiện tại có thể là đang
trống này thôi nhưng mà có những chỗ
khác gọi thẳng ul này thì nó sẽ bị báo
lỗi đấy thì cách để mình không bị lỗi
thì chỉ đơn giản là mình mình phải viết
test cẩn thận cho tất cả các tình huống
nó đang chạy ổn đúng không ạ
à và mình đây thì đầu tiên th cái bảng
này thì như tôi nói cái bảng này bản
chất là gì bản chất là cái bảng này sẽ
là để bên admin sẽ là người vào đây tôi
mở cho m ông admin
nhá Tôi nhớ không lầm là à Cái router
là bạn lỡ đặt tên qu router hơi dài thôi
đấy tôi tạm tắt cái ID để tôi đăng nhập
được
trang mặc định không có cái trang mặc
định thì phải nó sẽ bị lỗi Đúng rồi phải
vào cụ thể cái Trang do bot thì mới vào
được n tôi tắt cái này đi
vậy đó mặc định sẽ vào như này nó ổn hơn
tự nhiên vào tự nhiên trang trắng tinh
kia nó hơi sai sai
ờ đây thì bạn đấy thấy làm là bạn muốn
làm kiểu này bạn ấy làm kiểu dạng là bạn
hot code luôn cái mấy cái config kiểu
như này chọn file này đường dẫn ảnh là
gì như này này chọn kiểu dạng là inmate
này hot new này re này kiểu kiểu như
này tôi tôi không làm trực tiếp Làm đoạn
này nên nên là nên là cậu cũng không
hướng dẫn bạn đấy là đoạn này không
gọi như nào
nhỉ cái config ấy thì ừ thì nó có thể
làm homepage như này cũng được nhưng mà
nhưng mà theo tôi
thì nếu mà thế thì ít nhất là mấy cái
mấy cái kiểu như này tự nhiên mình sẽ
khi mà ông code mấy kiểu như này nó sẽ
người ta sẽ không hiểu được là tại sao
tự nhiên lại kiểu có phần trăm ở đây như
này Đấy c t là phần trăm xong rồi cái
hot new này là hot code hẳn ở một chỗ ấy
một chỗ đúng không Thì mình sẽ
kiểu gọi như này mình mình sẽ không thề
biết được là chỗ khác thì ông ghi hot
new có chữ S chẳng hạn chỗ chỗ này Không
lưu à không không ghi kiểu thế Mình
không ng mình sẽ để hết tất cả những
config Key config key ở một chỗ trong
code hoặc là trong đây đâu
đấy thường ở trong code thường ở trong à
thường là ở công ty tôi thường là sẽ ở
trong code Giả sử tôi sẽ ví dụ cho mấy
ông mấy ông dễ hình dung nhá Đấy nó sẽ
là config ke i5 như này
nhà chẳng
hạn đấy Xong rồi Ở đây tôi sẽ sửa lại là
config key i5 hot new đó như này thì về
sau tôi sẽ luôn muốn thêm một cái gì tôi
sẽ vào đây tôi thêm và tôi khi mà tôi
vào đây người khác vào đây người ta xem
được là à trong bảng config sẽ có một
cái Key là hot new nghĩa là không cần
trực tiếp vào thẳng ta B mà thể xem được
trong code luôn và mình quy ước nên quy
ước ở trong code không phải quy ước
trong DB thường là như thế xong DB đương
nhiên về sau mình sẽ lưu mình sẽ thường
an chạy một cái shed để mình lưu lại
những cái
này đúng rồi đây code lareal p
Ừ đúng là có những cái nghiệp vụ mà Có
thể tôi chưa biết được bạn đấy code kiểu
như này mình sẽ phải sửa lại new
theo ý tôi đó là chuẩn Cái Đoạn
này đoạn này ngoài cái slide ra không
nói còn Hình như là bạn ấy muốn cho
config luôn cả cái kiểu dạng là cái giao
diện kiểu hiển thị ra cái
ảnh mấy cái ảnh ở
đây để tôi thử thêm ảnh xem xem thế nào
Ảnh này đi
tôi mọi người sẽ được xem ảnh xếp
slide chẳng biết cái này bấm kiểu gì cơ
Cái này không phải để bấm mà đúng không
đợi tí đ đợi
này lắm thật
Ồ khó đấy th mà mình không hiểu nghiệp
vụ cũng hơi khó để
ở trong a đâu mình xem logic đoạn code
này nào đăng ảnh đâu post đẩy lên này
nằm trong store new arrival có cái ảnh
lên này Insert config new arrival các
thứ thứ như này đúng không đấy cái key
này này thì mấy ông sẽ phải ghi ở một
cái đâu
hiển thị đế cái gì lỗi tuyệt vời
ờ xem
à Lấy ra
value
Ừ Insert thì Insert báo thành công nhưng
mà bản chất là nó vẫn mình nhập vào đây
Nhập đường dẫn á nhập đường dẫn thủ công
á tôi cũng chưa hiểu đoạn này bạn đấy
làm
lắm bạn ul này là gì nhỉ Tại sao đây báo
lỗi
nhỉ Ok ở đây lỗi lại ngồi xem tiếp xem
Tại sao lỗi bộ 500 này đấy
Ờ có hướng dẫn sử dụng hay không á nên
tôi thì tôi còn đang đi mò
đây thế thế nên là chúng ta mới bảo là
làm cái Giả sử Giả sử khi mà Mấy ông vào
một cái code ở trên công ty người ta gửi
cho ông một đống code này x rồi bảo là
kiểu ông tự tìm hiểu đi xong rồi Kiểu
xong rồi còn giao ông làm thêm cái tt
thêm dẫn kiểu dạng tối ưu hay là kiểu
ngồi sửa lại làm thêm cái gì gì đó thì
mấy ông không để có chuyện đập đi làm
lại được khi mấy cũng không hiểu đúng
không
ạ m ông sẽ phải học cách kiểu đây học
giống như tôi đang học
code này thôi ok thì đây mình sẽ có một
cái
newel inmate này content
ba phát liền này hơi nhiều mình sẽ cân
mình về sau sẽ phải cân nhắc việc là Ừ
lấy hết toàn bộ confix ra rồi chạy đế
một
cách bạn Này bạn này cũng là kiểu cũng
là sinh viên thôi cũng không dành lắm
đây gợi ý định Vãi Còn gì
nữa Uầy ý đình thế Cái này chui vô ra
đấy Tạm xóa đi ạ
tại file homepage này Index này đâu để
tôi xem lại cái file này
xem nó Lỗi tại cái này gọi đến value
không có value nên nó báo lỗi Đúng không
nhở hay không có thằng này báo lỗi
ơ Nhữ vial nh nhưng mà đây lại new
content ha à Bạn ấy làm theo kiểu là là
hai cái này phải đi đôi với nhau nghĩa
là new rival ở đây phải có content ở đây
vãi chưởng tại sao ngay từ đầu cái này
không ôm luôn cả cái này nhỉ Nó sẽ hợp
lý hơn chắc là bạn ấy chưa làm được cái
vụ là kiểu là chèn ảnh vào trong nên là
bạn đấy dùng Tiny này chỉ gõ văn bản sau
đó thì thì bạn nhúng cái ảnh ở ngoài đấy
tôi bắt đầu hiểu dần rồi ok đoạn này làm
thế này không h hợp lý đúng không ạ đoạn
này là mình sẽ dùng một cái thực ra hồi
trước là sẽ có c Editor thằng C Editor
để mà mình sẽ kiểu nhúng luôn được kiểu
dạng là cả ảnh xong rồi các thứ các thứ
vào trong để dùng Nhưng mỗi tội ở thằng
này hình như nó mất phí
ồ Đợi tí thường là khi mà khi mà kiểu có
mấy cái giao diện này hình như là bạn
này cũng không dùng một cái template nào
đó thường là mình sẽ có một cái
template mình có một cái template để
mình có sẵn những cái bộ kiểu chỉnh sửa
như này ví dụ ví dụ nhá Tôi cho mấy ông
Xem V ví dụ Giả sử là đây bên admin thì
ví dụ admin LTE này có cho mấy ông kiểu
dạng
Advance đi À đây Editor chẳng hạn này
đấy m hoàn toàn thể nhập trong này một
cái gì gì đó như này thậm chí chè thêm
ảnh gì gì đó như này đấy sẽ có ảnh này
trong này sẽ có đoạn văn bản gì đó như
này thì ông sẽ đăng cái này ở trên ở
trên giao diện
luôn thằng này là Summer Note à xem
thằng này bởi vì bạn đấy đang dùng
à Bạn đã không dùng template tôi ngại
sửa giao diện lắm để để mình thử cái
riêng từng cái xem mấy cái thằng miễn
phí hay không
Ờ bạn ấy đang
dùng đầu tiên thì ở cái trang này này
trang giao diện này này tôi nghĩ là
ngoài dùng telescope ra tôi sẽ dùng luôn
cả tarel debug 3
đi để hiển thị luôn cái nhỏ nhỏ ở dưới
cho tôi dễ chọn còn làng telescope thì
thực ra nó sẽ có cái tiện của nhiều cái
này C
đỉnh
nhỉ Summer Note này CH chỉ sửa này
Ờ Download compline
đây các bạn sẽ thấy là mình biết được là
mình
đang cái này khó chịu
nhỉ Tôi không biết vứt cái này đi đâu
bây giờ nữa chuẩn là cái này nên hiển
thị ở một góc nào đó để mấy ông xem luôn
được được chứ không phải hiển thị trong
màn của
kiểu để cho cái tiện hơn thì mấy ông cứ
đề xuất tôi nhá
Ờ thôi cũng không phải người livestream
nhiều không để ý lắm và cũng ít cũng
không phải là người xem livestream nhiều
thì m ý xem
mọi người dùng cái
gì này có dùng cả Sweet alert các thứ
thứ này nhưng cái này có không biết là
cái này có có hiển thị ra kiểu Mình load
những cái ja Script gì không nhỉ Chắc
không rồi chắc mình vẫn phải gọi mình
phải mở cái inspect lên để xem
mình gọi Tiny nhớ phết này đúng
cái
kiểu còn chưa chắc là dùng hết Tuy là
dùng cái Min rồi đấy
content homepage
này
admin content
được gõ kiểu này N không ra
ex
section dưới này ra Script này mình dùng
cái Tiny cloud
hơi khó chịu nhìn cái đấy
admin
library Uầy nhiều phết
cũng hay này cho dù tôi chưa dùng bao
giờ cho mấy ông xem v cái Kill
tun gi sử mình là tí ch
đây đây th được mà dùng Kill này
này ấy mấy ông thấy là cũng chèn được
ảnh các thứ thứ nhẹ nhàng bình thường
thoải mãi đúng không Ảnh đ tôi chui
đó ngon mà đấy dùng cái này à Dùng thử
cái này
đi biết đâu nó đỡ hơn cái thằng thaii
kia tôi chưa dùng Tiny Tôi dùng mới dùng
mỗi
Ờ tính ra tôi mới dùng mỗi cái C hitter
thôi mà thời tôi dùng rất lâu rồi lâu
lắm rồi m động Z ấ nên
này Xóa đoạn này đi xem đùng phát lỗi
làm gì
[âm nhạc]
luôn sao tạm thay Min này thấy bạn cũng
làm mấy cái thứ cũng chật vật phết
tôi nghĩ là bạn ấy chưa dùng triệt để
hay là bạn ấy tạm tắt cái Đợi tí Hình
như bạn ấy còn tạm tắt cái đây tool 3 ừ
Bạn ghi đầy đủ tất cả cái này có khi bạn
tạm tắt xừ cái
phần chọn ảnh rồi nên thành ra bị
thế Tôi đang muốn là kiểu có chọn ảnh ở
trong này mà À đây có chọn ảnh
chọn ảnh nhỉ n thấy là bạn mới phải làm
hẳn cái riêng này đợi đợi tôi tí tôi thử
bật lên nã
lý vụ chọn ảnh rồi thì các bạn khi mà
chọn này thì các bạn rồi các bạn sẽ biết
được là là mình nó sẽ gọi đến gọi một
bước để xử lý cái vụ kiểu lưu ảnh
đây thường nó sẽ gọi thêm một cái nữa
này để mà xử lý cái vụ lưu ảnh cho các
bạn chuyền lên cái gì gì đó như này này
đấy thì các bạn phải xử lý cái đoạn
này tôi thử cho mấy ông xem lại nhá Còn
không thì nó sẽ báo lỗi
này upload lên
dẫn thì
phải nói chung là bạn ấy chưa xử lý được
cái vụ lưu ảnh của cái thằng Tiny này
Thành ra bạn mới dùng bạn mới làm thủ
công ở bên ngoài như này
Ờ bây giờ
tôi bây giờ tôi sẽ kiểu cũng chị
khó ngồi làm cùng mấy ông đi n Tôi sẽ
thử ngồi mò cái vụ Tiny này thô Tôi rất
ghét tôi rất ghét làm ra scp Ờ vì l lắm
mà không động lại cũng khá là mệt đấy
nhưng mà thôi Tôi tôi nghĩ là bây giờ
tôi dạy cho mấy ông mình phải chấ chấp
nhận mình phải cho mấy ông thấy là có
nhiều cái khó mình phải à làm quen
được được không
ạ không hề thích tẹ nào ngồi mò ra scrip
có thể các bạn từng thấy Tôi từng dạy
cái mấy cái dự án trước ngồi làm ra
scrip với giao diện mất xử hết một
đoạn này sau inmate cái này tôi nó không
hiểu
lắm đây new vial bạn ấy cũng làm là cũng
có theo quy tắc là kiểu về sau sẽ để ba
ngôn ngữ rồi nên sẽ dừng kiểu như này
nhá Nhưng mà thực ra là bên admin thc ra
là chỉ cần một ngôn ngữ tiếng Anh thôi
cũng được đó không nó khó hiểu lắm
Ờ thường đa ngôn ngữ mình sẽ làm đa ngôn
ngữ ở bên giao diện khách hàng còn không
thì thích thì mình để hết tiếng Việt ở
bên giao diện admin Toàn người Việt với
nhau mà mình để tiếng Anh làm gì đúng
không
không Tôi thấy là có rồi thì hiển đị
mà submit như này đúng không bản thất
bản thân cái này
là đâu xem
đấy luôn chưa nghe V
nào
code này thông cảm Thông
cảm ul ul ở dưới này ul Ok đoạn này giả
sử cứ xóa đi c xóa đi nhá xem form này ở
đây xóa đi thì sẽ
sao bùm kh khó rồi xóa đi sẽ sao Làm gì
mà cái này load lâu thế
nhỉ Mấy ông thấy Trang này load lâu
không trang này chứa cái gì vậy 11 giây
loát ạ đỉnh ấy Cái này mất
tận gì đấy mất 6 giây Á à đâu 6 m giây
thôi mà khiến nó loát lâu thấ nhỉ
nhỉ
ny lừa
rồi lại có cái gì đ khiến nó cái này VT
rất là
lâu cho dù trang này chẳng có cái gì
đãi tôi bắt đầu muốn đập V đoạn này làm
lại đây Ờ xem If empty à Vừa rồi empty
nghĩa vừa rồi Mình đang có một cái gì
đó đây đây mấy cái đoạn cần xóa này
ờ
đúng không and If ở đây ấy có cái If nào
đây e ở đây này If này
à đây Đoạn này đoạn enif của bạn đấy ok
bay luôn Tạm biệt
đang chạy cùng một lúc tôi sẽ tạm tắt
thằng telescope đi biết đâu nó sẽ khiến
nó đỡ đỡ đơ hơn không hiểu sao bị đâu
không
ok Tôi nghĩ là tôi
sẽ chơi kiểu tôi xóa xử hết toàn bộ ở
trên làm dần dần làm đến đâu đập hết đến
đấy mà quên mất Xóa xư hết trên đây
rồi nhưng mà tôi ngại làm lại giao diện
lắm tự nhiên Giả sử là bạn
đấy về sau mình làm mình lại phải sửa
mình Copy lại cái giao diện để tôi xem
đã hot new này để lại cũng được để chọn
cái tin tức mới nhất này
Ừ xong Phả submit rồi Trông nó mấy cái
này hơi
bị Hơi bị tệ về cái giao diện nhưng mà
tôi không trách được bạn đấy vì tôi làm
giao diện cũng tệ
Ờ cái này men đánh dấu này chọn không
biết tại sao bạn nghĩ ra cái cho chọn
file như này xong rồi hiển thị ul chẳng
hiểu để làm gì Ờ à hình như ul để bạn ấy
muốn
à Bấm vào cái cái ảnh đấy thì nhảy sang
cái trang nào đó tôi nghĩ là thế Cho dù
là nhìn cái tử ul này nó hơi tối
nghĩa CN nhiều làm trang loá lâu không
Thực ra CN nó cũng kiểu đương nhiên nó
không phải loal nên nó sẽ có thể loát
hơn một tí nhưng mà nhưng mà nó mà tùy
mạng của ông nữa vì thường là mấy
cái mấy cái cdn thường là nó cũng kiểu
mạng nó cũng đố gần Ừ có thể thằng này
sẽ khiến nó lâu này có thể
thế lên hẳn đây có hẳn lưu hẳn về Ơ
nhưng mà th thế Chứng tỏ là ông em này
chưa lưu
cái thai nghi này ở chỗ khác à m ông ông
chưa Lưu lại luôn ạ B trưởng 3 sao
đó
đấy lưu lại ở trong code
đi pan
charm
public Ông nói tôi mới ỉ
Tiny Mở xe
đó
đi vào trong
đây thì bây giờ mình sẽ có L này tin mce
hơn đỡ load load kiểu nặng nãy giờ có
khi là do
nh nghĩ việc load lại này là do nó load
một lần nhanh 2 lâu tôi nghĩ là do nó
render cái view BL lo lần hai rất là
nhanh
đọc hẳn tài liệu đ nhá chúng ta hôm nay
chúng ta sẽ ngồi đọc tài liệu ờ h thậm
chí ở dùng Chat VT đến giờ rồi Quyết mất
đâu để xem à đến giờ
nghĩ là dùng Chat tt
là mình
sẽ
chơi một
cái
xem basic
full Open x fixture
Ồ nó
đoạn
Chắc là chỉ có mỗi timing kia
thôi set này plug in này auto save aut
link này Ôi đoạn này làm gì dài thế xem
xộc gọi đến cái gì à
Không
m gì
cái một như này rồi cách ra dấu cách
á tool 3 này cũng thế ạ đỉnh
không cần m cái
đấy tra thằng Google
đi đây file inmate thì trả về T một cái
Google đấy đúng không rõ ràng nó gọi đến
cái cái CB ở một cái đâu đấy Hay bản
thân thằng này nó có sẵn cái hàm C này
nhỉ
picker co B bỏ qua như thế thì không hề
biết được là nó xử lý cái đoạn import
ảnh kiểu gì rồi
Ừ đến giờ rồi tôi sẽ thử hỏi chat VT
chat đây CHT 4 Chắc là nó cũng mới
là Tini mấy xem
Tiny
đây Tiny 6 luôn
Tiny m
ce6
example à
ạ đỉnh ấy B giờ đúng là thêm vài cái
đỉnh ấy
à proing luôn này ồ xịn quá xịn quá
visiting Tiny cloud
luôn Tôi đang dùng cái tài khoản của
công ty đấy Nên
là nên là kiểu nó mới kiểu có mấy chat
Active form submit không Mình không dùng
form đúng
không Đây inm ul mình sẽ gọi đến cái
đường dẫn này
đoạn này rồi bạn dùng cái này tôi bảo
vừa nãy tôi bảo đấy Chẳng hiểu ông ấy
khai báo cái này đâu ra ấy nhớ không có
khi trong code lỗi xư ra scrip ấ Xem
nà DEF level isu này
đây thử
cái này lỗi
này
lỗi gọi đến cái đường dẫn này
ông ấy lấy
Kiểu cái đoạn này lấy đô ra đường dẫn
này cơ định
xong nó sẽ trả về cái gì không biết trả
về cái gì
này
ok
Xem nà upload upload
handler mình sẽ gọi đến một cái router
nhưng mà router đấy Nó sẽ phải trả về
cái gì thì không
xem đâu nó chỉ giản gửi đi rồi mà xong
ngồi Đường
Dẫn đường
nữ đôi khi là mình cứ test trước đã
Ờ đây folder mình sẽ dùng cái kiểu này
chẳng biết handler này chui ra À đây nó
nằm trong một cái example nào đó này Bảo
sao
mình mình sẽ có một cái router để xử lý
router xử lý cái vụ lưu Thực ra là bạn
đấy bản thân bạn ấy đã làm
rồi
Đ đoạn code này đây đợ tí đâ để tí đợ tí
đ đoạn code này
lại cái này chí cái này chứ Mà cái gì
nữa đúng
không Đây chè cái đoạn link này vào thì
cái này nó sẽ lưu lại và bản chất là cái
này sẽ phải trả về một cái gì đó chạ
đứng dẫn hay cái gì gì
tại sao cái này load lâu ấy
nhỉ xem
nào
Why
à đâu
nó 200 m mà
gọi gì lát lâu nhỉ Uy DNS tận 10 giây
Uầy
[âm nhạc]
DN nào rồi ngại
trưởng
đây một cái cdn Sweet alert này
sao tự nhiên thấy load lâu
thế B chưởng
đợi tôi một tí đấy đúng có rất nhiều
việc để
nhỉ không biết mấy cái này điểmm gì
gì th viện này đểm gì
comment lại đã có thể đẩ có thể không để
lên nhưng mình comment lại đã cho mỗi
lần Loan không bị nặng kểu như thế s
alert gọi thằng này lại bằng kiểu gọi
nhỉ đúng
không như V nãy tôi xem có
Ok Thế mình Lư lại
thật Đôi khi chỉ những cái nhỏ nhỏ nhỏ
treo xứ quá
ơ nhầm
này đâu Tuy là các bạn được xem nhưng mà
có rất nhiều cái liên quan bảo mật V các
thứ thứ Nên là mình sẽ không chia sẻ cái
này lên cho các bạn được
lưu Library xong rồi s alert
nhỉ
DNS DNS là
domain cái này thực ra không phải cdn
đâu CS là cái khác mấy này loá Thực ra
cũng nhanh
mà lỗi tôi đấy mấy tất cả này đều loát
nhanh mà kêu mi dây
này nào chậm đâu ôi cái này h page là 10
giây này à Không cái này Trang thẳn
Trang này Không nói làm
gì mà cái trang này lắt DNS lâu thấ
cái nào nó bị nhầm đến nỗi nó không gọi
đến lá lâu khi sửa lại à khi load lại
thì load rất là
có phải do mạng
à Tại
local lại load l so DNS mất tận 10
giây nhưng khi tại lại trang lại rật
nhanh thử xem nó có gợi ý gì
không
lại lấy lại IP á IP này tôi confix ở
trong lúc mà chạy cái la dog ấy tôi
không bị tôi chạy mấy cái khác vẫn bình
thường mà tại sao thằng này rê thằng lâu
không
CPU cuu thoải mái mà
memory Uầy à Không cái này là do tôi cho
docker chạy Ngần này memory chứ th ra nó
không nhiều như
[âm nhạc]
này tôi nghĩ là do cái này
hơn xem
nào
tns thì start and rất là nhanh này Dom
thì tốn thời gian này Đấy bây giờ lại
lâu lại này tầm một lúc thì nó lại lâu
lại chẳng
hiểu
DNS cho là bị cái tình trạng này B
lar
DNS
chưa
Ờ Ừ tôi không biết được tôi có cấu hình
cái này chưa chắc phải cấu hình rồi nó
mới chạy đấy chứ
chậm Ờ tôi không nghĩ là tôi bị như thế
đâu thử xem nhá
[âm nhạc]
tối ưu hóa ồ tắt xdb Ừ tôi nghĩ cũng thể
do xdb của tôi tôi tạm tắt xdb đi xem
đang có thể đang chạy
và Chính nó khiến
cho kiểu dạng nó mà không chạy được có
thể nó sẽ khiến bị treo chẳng
hạn
mới run chứ
Trên này rồi Như
th Action nàyb xem đây đây
Ồ tôi nhớ là tôi có mở xdb nhưng mà
trong cái project khác không biết nó ảnh
hưởng gì đến thằng này
không Nhưng mà như ông mấy ông thấy thì
lúc mà khi mà đang chạy này nó đang bị
có thể có thể nó sẽ gây ra cái lỗi gì đó
không biết
cái này sau không lại mất thời gian của
mấy ông quá
ờ đầu tiên là ngồi sửa lại cái vụ
à quên Mở này
lên sự bây giờ mình gọi đến Mình chọn
một cái ảnh
đi Đấy nó sẽ gọi đến cái store này lưu
lại đúng không ạ
Ờ Gọi cái gì nó bị chậm
chất là nó không truyền cái
ptic cho nó bằng chu xem nào sắc add
copy À đây thử xem cái này
phẩy ở cuối có được không cơ
ờ ra skip mới nhất thì
BC fix cả tuần
được mà đương nhiên bây giờ Tôi ít bị
cái trường hợp đấy rồi đấy bây giờ loát
nhanh vã chưởng này đỉnh vãi
cái này là cái này do c c kiểu không
truyền không
truyền đủ
rồi đợ Đợi tí đợi t mình sẽ phải dùng
nhận
mình sử dụng cái kiểu như này đi đâu
Không phải Không phải mình sử dụng cái
handle như này đi mình sẽ khai báo một
cái ở đây rồi mình dùng
Hàn đó đây là inmate upload cái gì đó
như này đúng
không cái router
port cái gì gì
đó to g gì
đó invalid succeed thì trả về location Ồ
trả về cái kiểu đường gi ảnh đấy đúng
không mình nghĩa là mình sẽ
onero sau đó thì form lại s Tôi chưa
hiểu cái đoạn này lắm Tại sao mình lại
process
đây Ok
Ok không thuận the tự nhiên thường th
làm
lắm đây Cứ làm theo kiểu Thuận như th
này đi onload onero gì gì
Ok cái đoạn này tôi
sẽ mình sẽ phải truyền Thế tham số cho
nó đấy form này sẽ là một cái là
[âm nhạc]
không Mình sẽ thêm đây nà
upen
csrf đ g đi gợi ý
đi
Ơ kìa gợi ý
app
dưới Token thì
hết như này thì
nói đấy Mình ghi đúng á mất công vãi
chưởng
à thả
mà mình dùng Blue nên là nó à không dùng
Red thì phải Red hay
à
Ơ nó mất luôn cái kia
rồi mất cái upload của tôi rồi Ủa Alo
upload của tôi
đâu upload hander mà
luôn
à đây đây lỗi tôi lỗi tôi lỗi tôi lỗi
tôi một
nào gọi đến đây này đâu gọi đến rồi
cái gì nhỉ chưa thấy bao giờ
Ôi đến lúc phải mở lại telescope lên rồi
Tuyệt
cơ để đỡ đau mắt tôi sẽ chỉnh cho mấy
ông đắ đúng nhỉ telescope Có cái đắ mà
nhở tham
ấ thi bóng tối của tôi đâ
rồi
điều hướng ạ vãi chưởng
sao
Ok gọi đến Hàm
[âm nhạc]
này
Ờ r
back mình sẽ chả về cái mình lưu lại
à không lưu lại ảnh à À đấy store đấy
lưu lại ảnh trả về đường dẫn
đây đường dẫn đây mình sẽ Return về cái
đường dẫn đây alert ao Ui Cái này hay
nhỉ chưa dùng cái này bao
giờ
Nhưng mà mình
sẽ để xem đợi đợi xem lại nhá ero create
miit ero đây bản chất bản chất ấy đó là
mấy ông nên làm vad đoạn này chứ không
phải kiểu như này
Ờ đợi tí cái này
là tôi sẽ viết tôi bảo làm đến đâu đập
đập bên đấy mà đúng không Thì bây giờ
mình sẽ sửa lại cái đoạn này tí đầu tiên
là mình
sẽ cái này bản chất là mình sẽ lưu lại ả
đúng không Mình ờ À quên trước mắt thì
tôi code đến đâu làm đến đấy chuyên
nghiệp đến đấy cho mấy ông m ông tham
khảo đấy thường là khi mình code cái gì
đó ví dụ đoạn code lạ hoắc này mình
chẳng hiểu tại sao có đoạn code này ra
đời đúng không Mình sẽ luôn ghi một cái
chú thích ở đây như này
đó để mình hiểu được à ta copy đoạn code
nằm ở đoạn này đấy Kiểu thế thì về sau
kiểu người sau sẽ hiểu đoạn code này ra
đời từ từ đâu đúng
không tiếp theo là bây giờ sang bên này
bản thân là tôi sẽ không sửa về cái
router của bạn này router thôi giữ
nguyên
bạn ấy
dùng khai báo cái rter này nằm trong nằm
trong đâu vậy à đây
Ok name này store này store
gạch sưới như này đâu thường là viết
kiểu kiểu như này thì nó sẽ hợp lý hơn
Ừ đấy Ông thấy hình hoảng hướng gạch
dưới cái như này hướng lên kiểu viết
ngao sẽ không ngổn nó lắm đúng không
ha Nhìn này gạch dưới đỉnh
thật nhưng mà thôi ta bỏ qua vụ này
Nhưng mà nếu để viết thì viết file
request thì mình sẽ phải viết nó chuẩn
chỉ một tí
Ờ mình sẽ tôi sẽ viết kiểu như này đi
Tôi viết tắt một cái là Pa rồi pp
addition đ Xem p thì vậy tôi sẽ viết tắt
như
này Pa này đây pam đi làm m một cái gì
đó như
này
hẳn cụ thể đi
p pamr đi make request n
hỗ trợ mình viết test thôi
làm nhiều file request phết Mỗ tội là
không nằm trong một cái thư mục nào đó
cụ thể mình ở đây mình sẽ là thư mục
admin homepage này chẳng
hạn admin này homepage
bảo nên để tên hàm nó hợp lý hơn nó sẽ
là đây store new AV
inmate lưu lại cũng được sẽ đặt tên lại
đến Hàm này
phát để mình hiểu được thì mình cũng là
một cách hay kiểu bây giờ mình sẽ biết
được là khi
Khi mà mình đổi tên hàm này rồi đồng
nghĩa việc là là mình đã sửa cái file
sửa đến cái đoạn này
đúng không Trông tên rất là dài Vừ
lại sẽ làm gọn hơn nhiều au này Thực ra
là thường là mình có kiểm tra mid away
về cái au rồi nên tạo mở
qua thường ghi kiểu như này thôi
mình sẽ có một cái file ở đây file là
mình đặt tên là inmate à Nó chuyền mình
file lên là cái gì
nhỉ lúc vừa nãy mình đặt tên có khi mình
đặt tên là file th thì phải
Ờ đấy Đúng rồi Tôi nhớ mà đặt tên là
file thôi ok
file require Ồ quá đỉnh xị
đái gip luôn Đấy thế là đơn giản rồi bây
giờ mình sẽ có
store request như này C như mình sẽ bỏ
đi đi được cái đoạn
xave thì
không thôi Thực ra tôi không thường hay
không để ý khi mà lưu này nó bị lỗi gì
gì đó đâu đâu
ok chuẩn ấy đó là chuẩn là mình phải đấy
có cái file ở đây
toàn bộ như này nó hợp lý hơn chứ không
phải xử lý ở ngoài như này đằng nào Cái
này cũng là config mod của bạn ấy này
Đấy file
nhá đây và cái đường dẫn này Thực ra
mình nên nên xử lý ở một chỗ khác kiểu
mình hot code ở một chỗ nào đó hợp lý
request gọn
đi Mình không dùng đấy nữa
mình sẽ Return
về tôi nhớ là
này chứ không
sẽ trả về một cái inage name này chẳng
hạn
trường hợp nà nó chả về phone à
ok
ừ
đây n mà không có thì mình
sẽ alert Arrow cái gì gì đó đây phết nhỉ
sẽ
à thông một cái exception
này to upload nha Chẳng
hạn
một cái image như này Ok
về như này thôi trả về string thôi vì rõ
ràng là bản chất là thằng này nếu mà
fail thì mình đã thông một exception rồi
mình sẽ gọi như này Hạn chế dùng cái đô
la K ngay nhá À Hạn chế dùng gọi đến cái
hàm như kia
ờ đó tôi vừa sửa lại mấy ông thấy là cái
controller nó khá là ngắn gọn hơn hơn
đúng không Mình tách tách những cái vai
de ra một chỗ
trông cũng không hổn nữ lắm như gi thi
tạm vậy
nhỉ Mấy ông thấy tôi nhảy sang B en làm
mượt hơn không sang fan làm làm nó cứ
kiểu bị chậm ấy trả
Easy
mở lên là xong ngon
phết nhìn n đó Trông đẹp hơn hẳn đúng
cái này rồi một đường dẫn này
rồi
und defy reading Zen bị lỗi bị lỗi ở tại
cái
invalid à Nói yêu cầu mình trả về Jon
Nhưng mà mình nhưng mà mình lại trả về
kiểu này Ừ đúng mình nên chả về J th ra
hồi trước từ từng viết cho bạn đấy một
cái
là cái một cái
chết chết nhưng không phải chết đâu
nhá Sếp tôi từng gọi nó là chết
Ờ cái chết để mà respond về một cái Ờ
succeed đây tôi hướng dẫn mấy ông viết
một cái
đây class là chết như này Đây là api
respon chết
respa đy hạn chất là mình truyền về là
Data là gì đó Gửi ý này rất là chuẩn này
có vẻ là đọc code của mình từ đâu đó
rồi
Đúng không
nhỉ Tập code này từ dự án khác của tôi
đấy hai hàm kỉ niệm vậy chưa Ừ hình như
tôi từng dạy mấy ông v cái này mà đúng
không
Ừ 500 là đúng rồi phone như này ok đó
chúng ta đã có hai hai hàm đúng không
Đấy Bây giờ mình sẽ không trả về kiểu
Bull xong rồi string như vừa rồi nữa
mình trả về chuẩn nó sẽ là doit
à đấy như này nhưng mà đương nhiên mình
sẽ phải ưu cái chết này ở trên này
ưu
ông xem nhá Đấy mấy ông thấy tôi sửa
nhiều không thấy do Hạn chế dùng
refactor nhá Cái này còn đang không tì
thấy này cứ tạm xóa đi lỗi mình sẽ sửa
sau thì đằng nó chẳng lỗi vì nó không Tí
thấy mà
Chắc chắn rồi
đấy Đó bây giờ nó mới chuyên nghiệp hơn
này
V tí data trả
về Ok chạy thử lại không biết được
khôngi vì nó chết ra scrip
hiểu thật không hiểu bởi vì cái này là
nó nâng cao các bạn phải xem cái
playlist cũ của mình để mà hiểu hơn mình
đang à xem cái từ cơ bản đã xem cái mới
này công nhận là bạn sẽ không hiểu lắm
đâu Follow not function on load ha Mình
đang dùng một cái hàm Follow
đây thường là cái sắc xit này chú đâ ra
nhỉ
ơ sắc
sút à Rồi rồi rồi Tôi hiểu rồi Mình làm
gì có chấm location mình chấm data mà
lỗi tôi lỗi
này
Ờ xem
khác
lỗi gì
đây
l
i. Total upload
này Xóa đoạn này đi Hình như cái đấy là
để mà hiển thị kiểu đang upload được bao
nhiêu
phải bao nhiêu phần trăm ấy thì phải
chúng ta không cần đều đấy Ở
đây Tại sao vẫn không được nhỉ Công nhận
mất kiế nhẫn đ Cái này phết này data trả
về một cái đường dẫn rồi mà
Ờ tôi đang nghĩ là nó fail là bởi vì là
cái đường dẫn này nó không hoàn toàn
đúng lắm Mình phải có một cái
asser nữa đường dẫn kiểu đầy đủ hơn cái
này có vẻ đang không đúng rồi Cái này
à đợi tôi một tí rồi xem nhá trả về
về ở đây Tôi nghĩ là cần một cái kiểu
Đây bởi vì mình sẽ cần gọi cái đường dẫn
asset này nữa này xong mình nhúng vào
thì nó hợp lý
hơn chắc
một đường dẫn tương đối
rồi này upload này thì bản chất là mình
chỉ cần trả về st st part thôi Hình như
thế
part à
xem Ừ public part
này C Editor được em dùng C Editor Nếu
mà kiểu nó không TH phí càng tốt Anh
đang bởi vì là bởi vì là
Ờ bạn cũ bạn đang dùng cái này nên anh
kiểu muốn chỉ mọi người cách kiểu mò cái
đạn này nó như nào anh cũng đang mò mà
Chứ thực ra là các bạn mà dùng cái cái
khác được thì cứ dùng thôi đúng
rồi
on sao nó vào Lỗi tại Dòng này được nhỉ
ơ code của nó vẫn là location này hình
như là nó đang dùng code cũ của tôi đ
xem
nào Hình như nó đang dùng code cũ nó mới
báo Cái lỗi này được chứ
quả location
là Pa này clear cách
này à đâu view clear này
Đấy đôi khi là thằng larel nó sẽ cách
lại cái view này cách toàn bộ code ở
trong cái view nên thành ra có thể nó sẽ
bị lỗi kiểu như này không phải là nó
cách ra scrip
unitest tôi tôi chẳng nhớ là công ty tôi
chính xác là có dùng unitest hay là chỉ
fixture test nữa nên chắc chắn tôi sẽ
demo mấy ông về vụ test sau Ờ kiểu gì
hôm sau tôi sẽ làm cho mấy ông về mấy
cái test nhiều đấy code này rõ ràng là
đây là code cũ mà nhỉ
Ừ đợi tí tôi phải chơi clear hết
là code cũ hay không nữa để tôi thử nhá
Để thử nhá comment hết là lạ đoạn này
này giả sử Thế xem thực sự ở đây đang
code cũ hay code
lại được file đó Ừ thì mình có lưu được
mà b en Thì mình vẫn làm Lưu Bình thường
clear
Đúng rồi hình như optimize clear đúng
rồi nó lắm không động vào thường tôi
cũng chưa bị dính cái quả này mấy tôi
bảo Lâu lắm rồi mới động lại
bên giao diện mà optim
V
phím tắt vào cái này
thương rồi tôi thương để nó là PC chẳng
hạn clear
đấy
tôi comment hết lại cả cái này đi xem
thực sự là nó còn hiển thị ra một cái gì
đó không Yeah có vẻ nó vẫn nhận đấy
lỗi nó còn báo sai cơ à đây đây đây đây
Ok cảm ơn bạn mình đã biết
được
chấm đâu bình tĩnh bình tĩnh ở đây gọi
Chỗ này sai à màu nó khác khác nhỉ Lại
nhỉ À rồi rồi lỗi tôi lỗi tôi quen quen
pp kểu nối chuỗi bằng dấu dấu chấm ạ
Ok chạy yeah lỗi khác hay là do lại cách
rồi
nhỉ Sợ
lắm Chẳng lẽ mỗi lần mình lại phải clear
C
lỗi trọng mình đang không biết lỗi cái
chỗ
đúng không
Chắc thế đợi tí tôi sẽ cách để đây mình
sẽ controller ch
loock thực sự Cái đường dẫn này nó là
như nào
này rồi
đây
Đúng rồi Đường Dẫn này sai
rồi đã hiểu tại
sao Xem lại đường dẫn ảnh của bạn đấy
làm tôi lâu lắm không động thật rất là
xin lỗi lắ Không động vào mấy cái này
nên là nhầm về mấy cái
này đây
asset ồ bạn ấy phải làm kiểu
này Ok bắt trước
thôi không phải public mà là asset đoạn
này nhưng mà đợi đợi ch tí Đợi tí bạn
đấy asset như th này á
cái đường dẫn rồi mà
này rồi mà Tại sao bạn ấy còn nối thêm
cả cái p này phát nữa Vãi chưa Cái này
mới thử nhá thử mới biết được đúng không
một tiếng đồng hồ chỉ ngồi sửa sửa mỗi
cái giao diện thề tôi khó chịu vã trưởng
Tôi nhớ Tôi nhảy sang larel à nhảy sang
p à Nhờ bend vừa rồi vèo vèo đúng không
sang bên này chậm vã
đây ảnh ơ ảnh bị lỗi à đấy tôi thấy rõ
ràng ảnh bị lặp lại này thấy không Tại
sao bạn ấy thể làm được kiểu đấy nhỉ
annh lại không được này nào đợi đợi tôi
tí Đợi tôi một
tí upload inmate
homepage Hình như có gì đó Ở đây không
ngộn
rồi Ờ bạn đấy nằm trong thư mục upload á
được ý để xem nà nẽ có ra được ảnh không
Ừ nãy giờ có lưu được ảnh đâu phải
chưởng bảo
sao Đừng Đúng rồi rõ ràng nãy gi không
lưu ảnh không lưu ảnh nhưng không bản
lỗi Ok đâ xem nào Có Phil ở đây thâu gì
đó không Không Ok h chất là nãy giờ
lưu được ảnh th phải trả về nó là inm
name Nó phải là Bull xong rồi Thằng này
nếu không có mình thâu ở đây rồi mà
nhỉ hơi lạ
a tôi đã có câu ở đây rồi
cái Ờ storage link kia kìa tôi tôi tôi
có biết vụ đấy nhưng mà tôi thử xem là
tại sao nãy giờ không lưu được ảnh
mà không bắn
vẫn có vẻ nó vẫn trả về là
Chu ảnh đấy ở đâu thì T thì mình không
biết đúng
mục storage app này à Nếu thế storage
link chưa có
rồi
lửa
đâu Where my
exist à đây
đây có
nó phải vào đây
chứ nó vào thư mục lli nữa
mà hay là nó
chỉ Chắc là nó kiểu dạng là short cut
đến thôi
không
nhá Không nó là thế đấy Chẳng qua bên m
nó hiển thị cái này
được ảnh đỉnh thật đấy Hay là do Ờ gọi
đến là thư mục
E1
đường link này ra vả trưởng này chứ cho
không phải rồi Cắt bớt đi
này không được
ừ
public
chường đỉnh thật đấy Thế mà code cũ n
làm gì có nhắc đ storage
nhỉ À đây đây đây ơ thế Cái này là cái
tôi lỗi
Tôi xin lỗi các
ấy đoạn này không biết nó chạy được hay
không quá
đỉnh quá
lừa nó tự mình lừa mình thôi biết sao
giờ vẫn lỗi rồi
đây Story part
này
Đấy copy đoạn này
à này xong chắc ăn cơm ngon lắm
block của tôi luôn à lại optimize Ok Ok
anh
nhem lú
ơ link kiểu gì này link kiểu này sai đấy
[âm nhạc]
rồi
part kiểu kia được thường là tôi nhớ là
có gọi được stor part mà
đâu
lâu
thế cái gì có cái gì đâu l ảnh lâu thế
Alo Đấy đúng ảnh rồi
được lừa
lắm s SH này để làm
gì trời ôi kiểu sờ tự nhiên hóa ra tất
cả đoạn codt này chỉ để đểo
không thôi ổn
đấy
Sao có khi nào do mấy cái đoạn này
upload nh hay
dùng vừa nãy dùng kiểu này rồi là bắt
trước của cái trang chủ nó thôi không
không gợi ý được thêm cái gì
Chuẩn bị tiến rơ Buông xuôi rồi
là tôi đang nghĩ là do cái đường dẫn đầy
đủ này khi gây lỗi đường dẫn th ta ở mức
tương đối thôi Chưa thấy cái vụ đường
dẫn đầy đủ kiểu như
copy thử
nhỉ Không cho copy
à copy
upload đing
thể Cái này bản chất là nó trả về th cái
gì gì đó hay là do cái vừa nãy mình xóa
đi
nhỉ Đừng mà cái v nấy tôi xóa đi nhá Xóa
cái đoạn process này đ nhưng cái này là
on possess mà thế nó chả nghĩa gì cả cốt
để chuẩn là nó để hiển thị cây đang chạy
đi đâu
giờ Bây giờ mới chạy được Thì quá
dùng bất kỳ cái gì gì đó nó sẽ ngon hơn
rất nhiều dùng cái ja scrip tệ như này
tôi chỉ đang hướng dẫn mấy người kiểu
không phải hướng dẫn mấy người dùng ja
scrip
đâu code để khi mà debug thì mình xử lý
như nào thôi đấy not a function
này cút của nó
Ơ nãy giờ mình đang đọc cái n À
ủa
của năm
nhá
mọi thứ đều ổ mọi thứ
đều thứ đều
ổn thằng demo này còn chẳng có cái gì cả
quá
đâ Insert được ảnh
đâu gọi update ảnh lên cho vui
thằng thằng em tôi nó nó tạo hắn một cái
form riêng rồi
đấy ch bất lực
upad ảnh của thằng chin nó chơi cho kiểu
ta ản form riêng thì up lad annh quá
đỉnh Ơ upl này xem
nào xế xo nào Ồ ra được ảnh này ồ Đỉnh
đấy đâu phần upload ảnh
đâu inmate này Advance này bỏ qua bỏ qua
không cần up loạn không cần Advance rồi
thì nữa đâu đâu đâu We cho inmate tiếp
làm gì có
inm inmate Advance inmate Lead inmate
không Cái t ba đâu ảnh hưởng gì không
á
nh đâu thử copy à thử vào bộ trang này
xem l lâu không nhá Có vẫn l
lâu chứ rọ là do vấn đề về cái không
phải do code mà do tôi chỉnh cái gì đó
rồi
rồi t check config
King mớii thấy đoạn này
tôi sửa kiểu gọi
là chưa biết thể sai ở chỗ nào
còn shitter các product khác nhau thì
dùng cái hàm fake của nó ấ
Ừ đâi tí tí đang hơi loạn rồi auto save
auto save nà chai inmate x mào đấy
handling inmate upload ra 6
Ồ hóa ra Nãy giờ dùng n
nữa à quên Thằng chity chỉ hỗ trợ à đâu
nhưng mà nó có PR sin rồi mà V sinh rồi
gợi ý mình dùng n ạ quá đỉnh gửi mình L5
reject suc cả phone của nó valu của nó
đồ đấy bảo sao không À đây có thằng
process của nó mà không xem chạy
chạy
thôi thôi có niềm tin m không
ạ trước khi code chưa chạy à trước khi
Đúng rồi trước khi code chưa chạy chúng
ta vẫn có niềm tin là nó chạy
được con người rất là lạc quan
luôn yeah nó còn lỗi K
not4 à Ok khai báo trước l Tôi lội tôi
đấy cái này xuống dưới bình tĩnh bình
tĩnh
bùm
đó chạy nào bùm ồ
4 đáng mua ấy nhỉ
Ờ chúng ta nhiều lúc nên tự thân vận
động lên hẳn trang chủ của
nó tìm kiếm đọc đg nó sẽ hợp lý hơn đừng
tin cái thằng ai nào cả hiể Không nhá
Không thì mất hơn tiếng rưỡi để ngồi tin
tưởng nó
scam
xong sa hai tiếng rưỡi chúng n đã thêm
được cái hảnh vào tro cái
form
Ui Tự nhiên tôi cảm thấy là kiểu Tôi
muốn nhảy sang view js rồi đấy Kiểu dùng
Framework ja Script để đỡ phải quay lại
cái J
đó là hôm trước tôi có nói với một bạn
đó là đó là
kiểu các bạn đôi khi phải phân biệt cái
sở thích về Đam mê là như nào Sở thích
là kiểu bạn thích làm cái đấy Còn đam mê
là bạn thể kiểu khên ăn khuyên ngủ làm
nó nhưng ngoài ra ấy đó
là đó là bạn cái đam mê của bạn là bạn
để ý bạn gọi là thích cái cảm giác từng
tí một của nó kể cả những lúc khó khăn
như này ví dụ Giả sử Tôi nói tôi đam mê
Cái
như này đương nhiên tôi cũng đau đầu
cũng khó chịu cũng kiểu dạng là muốn
nghỉ để mà đi giải tỏa Nhưng mà khi mà
xử lý được xong ấy Ví dụ xử lý xong như
này tôi cười tôi vui tôi lại kiểu lấy
lại nhiếm tin ở lại cuộc đời lại tới đẹp
kiểu thế
Hồi trước sinh viên tôi cũng như thế nĩ
là nhiều sinh viên kiểu khi mà nó giải
quyết được xử lý được xong quả bấc ấ Ui
nó vui nó sướng nó Gao thét C thứ thứ
đấy Kiểu thế thì có vẻ là nó tìm được
Đam mê nó hợp với cái ảnh này vui khi
fix được bấc nhưng có những bạn mà kể cả
bạn đấy sửa xong được bấc rồi bạn ấy
kiểu chỉ cảm thấy áp lực bạn cảm thấy là
khi mà xong Bạn không cảm thấy được giải
tỏa hơn và bạn ấy còn cảm thấy là
là kiểu Ờ không muốn không muốn làm công
việc này nữa không muốn gặp cái áp lực
này nữa đây kiểu thế đấy thì theo tôi đó
là
ông để thực sự là ông biết được ông có
đam mê phù hợp với ngành lập trình này
tôi không biết ngành khác như thế nào
thì m ông cứ phải làm thử một cái đồ án
kểu này xong rồi khi gặp bấc Chắc chắn
là cũng sẽ mất mất nhiều thời gian hơn
tôi đấy để mà xử lý xong rồi Khi mà sửa
xong ấy mấy ông cặp thấy thế nào mấy ông
thấy kiểu Vui Vẻ hay là cảm thấy chỉ
thêm áp lực cảm thấy là không bao giờ
muốn sửa không mu muốn gặp bấc không
muốn sửa bấc nữa thì chắc chắn là có thể
công việc không phù hợp với ông lắm Nếu
thật sử kiểu đấy ông sửa được Xong Xong
ông lại gáy như tôi chẳng hạn thôi lại
vui yêu đời trở lại thì thì ông bị
nghiện rồi đấy súng tôi Long nghiện anh
Long nghiện kể Thế thì chắc là có thể
Ông cũng gọi là quen khổ quen được cái
khổ này
đấy Kiểu kiểu khổ nge rồi sướng không
chịu được ý thích có
tí Khổ dâm à Mới kiểu
thế
đấy đấy góc nhìn của tôi Ôi bây giờ cũng
lên 2 rư rồi 2 tiếng rưỡi ngồi
livestream chỉ vì ngồi fix BC lỗi tôi
khi mà tôi làm mấy ông có thể thấy hơi
mất thời gian Tí mấy ông nên ông nào xem
được đến cái giây phút này mà vì sau gọi
như thường à thường là câu kinh nghiệm
vố giơ ấy đó là trước khi đọc hay Xem gì
Thường An kéo xuống cuối để xem trước
cái cái kết đã đấy thì về sau ông
livestream mà ông nên kéo xuống cuối để
mà xem được cái kết nào chứ ông nào mà
ngồi xem từ đầu cái video này hai tiếng
thì chắc là thấy tôi chỉ ngồi lọ mọ cái
th thứ thì cũng mệt
[âm nhạc]
đấy thôi Bây giờ cứ tạm nghỉ nhá Tôi còn
đi ăn tủi đã chào mấy ông nhá Chắc đây
sẽ ra một cái Podcast khiến mấy ông gọi
là dễ ngủ không lắm đoạn cuối nó giật
mình một tí vì thì tôi gào lên trong
sung sướng
cũng rất lâu rồi mới gặp lại nói chuyện
với các bạn nên là các bạn cũng kiểu
chào các th thứ thì các bạn nếu mà có
thắc mắc hay có câu hỏi gì thì cứ có cái
link link để các bạn bấm vào phần mô tả
họ đá các thứ thứ nhá
Ừ cho các bạn nhá tôi đi ăn cái